good morning heck it's tuesday so i
wrote this book the anthropocene
reviewed which is a collection of essays
reviewing different facets of the
human-centered planet on a five-star
scale
i am very grateful and a little
surprised that the book has found such a
wide readership it has now been on the
new york times bestseller list for eight
consecutive weeks and my initial
assumption that everyone who read the
book would be like someone who watches
these videos turns out to have been
wrong
like just today i got an email that had
no joke the all-cap subject line
grandmother loves your book and i was
like sadly my grandmothers are not here
to read it so how could they love it but
it turns out it was someone else's
grandmother
and it was just such a kind and sweet
email so thank you catherine from
minnesota i give your email five stars
which reminds me that one of the
weirdest things about the last eight
weeks is that the book explores the
simultaneous absurdity and
indispensability of the five-star scale
and of course it is now widely being
reviewed
on a five-star scale in nice news on
both goodreads and amazon the
anthropocene reviewed has a
much higher average rating than any of
my other books it also for the record
has a higher average rating than macbeth
which
you know possibly indicates some
problems with the five star scale
but i have to confess i have read some
of these reviews of my book of reviews
and after reading them i felt it was
necessary to go deeper and review the
reviews of my book of reviews before i
do this though i just want to say if you
read the book and want to review it
that's great but please don't go through
reviews and like say mean things to
people
okay let's start with a two star review
that reads in part behind green's
ideological views i recognize the
typical characteristics of a man
with essentially feminine instinct thank
you
chef's kiss five stars but the best two
star review
starts out something like hank green
certainly knows his science but he
doesn't know anything about people
unfortunately i have to give that review
two stars because
on several levels it unjustly maligns my
brother
okay a more positive one on goodreads
someone gave it four stars and wrote
this is such a soft book
i love it that is exactly what i wanted
to do i wanted to write a soft book for
a hard moment
now i mean if you loved it you could
have given it five stars but then again
i gave the cave paintings at lasko four
and a half stars so maybe i should just
shut up and be grateful that said of
course i can only give you review four
stars
another nice one someone named gabriella
wrote equal parts stubborn hope and
self-awareness
there are many things my cynicism has
managed to withstand over time
but i found it difficult to hold on to
it in the face of such tender
vulnerable and heartfelt essays geez
thanks gabriella it occurs to me that
there is nothing more radical or
countercultural at the moment than
laying down one cynicism
in favor of tender vulnerability
five-star review
also on goodreads someone gave the
anthropocene reviewed three stars and
described it as a little ted lasso like
which buddy if you think i'm gonna be
disappointed about you calling my book
ted lasso like
you are mistaken i give your three-star
review five stars
in one of my very favorite reviews a
deal wrote in part if there was ever a
book that reminds us of what it means to
be alive
then this is it which i mean i wrote it
to remind me
what it means to be alive so yeah thank
you five stars
and then we have melissa who wrote in
part as a covid nurse the reflections in
this collection have helped me find my
white-knuckled way through this pandemic
which melissa the idea is that i make
you cry
okay not not not the other way around
here's the thing hank almost all the
reviews are like that
and i can't riff on them or make jokes
about them because they are so
open-hearted and
thoughtful and they evince the very sort
of generosity of spirit that i tried to
bring to writing the book
i don't really have any clever
rejoinders to that kindness
all i can say is a deeply felt but
wholly
insufficient thank you thank you
thank you hank i'll see you on friday
p.s if you haven't read the anthropocene
reviewed yet there are still signed
copies available or you can get it at
your local library or you can get the
audio book read by me
if you want you know like 10 hours of
this monotonic baritone
is monotonic a word it should be